SUEZETTE ROBOTHAM: My name
is Suezette Yasmin Robotham.
And I am the lead for
GBOP Diversity Channels.
And I'm really excited
to have all of you here
this morning-- go, team
GBOP-- for a very exciting
conversation with someone.
It feels like bring my brother
to work day, but a really
exciting conversation
with David Johns, who
is the executive
director, the White House
Initiative for
Educational Excellence
for African-Americans.
I did it.
DAVID JOHNS: Gold star.
SUEZETTE ROBOTHAM: All right.
And so we're going to start
with a very brief video,
and then get into
our conversation.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Ponics is hydroponics,
which is this,
which is physically grown by
the ammonia of the fish, nitrite
which turns into nitrate.
And that is good for the fishes.
It's good for the
fish and the plants.
And the reason why our water
is green, because of the algae.
So we leave it green like
this till it filters out.
And the good thing
about this system
is it's a closed system, so
all we have to do is feed it.
[END PLAYBACK]
DAVID JOHNS: So a
little bit of context.
This young man is-- when
I met him, at the time,
he was a high school senior at
Booker T. Washington in Miami.
Booker T. is one
of two schools that
are really known mostly for
being located near projects.
This one in
particular is located
near one that produced
Trick Daddy and Trina,
and then sending a significant
number of black boys
to the NFL every year.
Brandon had been shot on the way
to school earlier in the school
year and was in
school on his prom day
to give me a tour of
his senior thesis, which
was this aquaponics system
that they developed.
And his hypothesis
was that crops grown,
and a particular,
certain number of crops
grown, in this aquaponics
system would yield better
than the seeds that they planted
on a portion of their football
field.
And I try and share this
for a couple of reasons.
It's in a larger
presentation which is really
about the importance of,
one, listening to kids,
two, really honoring that
they all have genius.
Asa Hilliard talks
about, I've never
met a child, in
particular a black child,
who was not a genius.
And there's no secret
to how you support them.
The first thing you do is to
acknowledge them as human.
And Brandon, in particular,
attends a school
that most people would,
like, roll up their windows,
lock the doors, and just
drive by as fast as possible.
But through an
innovative partnership
with Florida International
University and JP Morgan Chase,
he has access to knowledge that
literally has turned a food
desert into a food forest.
And he has a sophisticated
understanding of agriculture
that is literally
transferable around the world.
And so he is an
example of what happens
when we move past a
lot of the stereotypes
that otherwise prevent us from
showing up from young people
and really pouring
into them in ways
that allow them to demonstrate
just how brave they are.
SUEZETTE ROBOTHAM: Thank
you for that, David.
And so I want to start by just
talking about the journey.
So something that's
really important in terms
of being a Googler
and being Googly
is understanding how people
ended up where they are.
And I know that I've had
the opportunity to hear
your story several times.
But you didn't know you were
going to be an educator.
And I don't know if
any point in your life
you imagined that you'd be
working for the White House
under the Obama administration.
So that is amazing.
But how did you get to
your job and your role?
DAVID JOHNS: Yes.
So three things come to mind.
One, this job didn't
exist five years ago.
It was a position
that was created
by President Obama and
part of the directive
of the Congressional
Black Caucus.
But we now exist as
one of six White House
initiatives that
focus on filling
population-specific gaps.
So prior to this
administration, there
were White House
initiatives focused
on historically black
colleges and universities, one
focused on educational
access for Hispanics,
another focused on education
access for Asian-American
Pacific Islanders, one focused
on Native American, Alaska
Native, Native
Hawaiians, and then one
slightly different focused on
faith-based and neighborhood
partnerships.
But if you look at
a lot of the data
around quality of
life indicators,
black people are often
at the lowest rungs,
particularly with regard
to education and workforce
development.
And so that was
really important,
in terms of establishing an
office so that there would
be someone who was unapologetic
and intentional in trying
to close both opportunity
gaps and achievement gaps.
Specific to the question of
whether or not I saw myself,
A, being an educator,
or B, working
for this administration,
the answer is, hell, no.
I'm from Inglewood, California.
I often joke that I didn't
watch "West Wing" until I was
well into DC a couple of years.
The idea of working in
policy was not something
that I thought
about, in particular
because I went to
Columbia University, where
people are taught to take over
countries and corporations.
So the idea that I
would become a teacher
was something that
a lot of people,
including myself,
couldn't comprehend.
And so the way that
that happened, I think,
is in part just
natural connections.
A lot of this is grace.
I took a bus ride
an hour each way
to and from school from
Inglewood, California
to Pacific Palisades.
I don't know if you guys
know Southern California,
but each way, to
Brentwood Elementary,
then to Paul Revere
Middle School,
then to Pacific Palisades
High School, sometimes going
to schools closer to
Inglewood, but always
at some point returning
back to those schools that
were the promise of potential.
And then, at
Columbia, the idea was
to pursue a JD-PhD,
because I like to argue.
When you're black, and in
college, and you like to argue,
and don't want to go
into medical school,
they say you should be a lawyer.
And so I thought about
that for a while.
But my freshman year somebody
told me about the fact
that I could pose
a question and then
be paid to research the answer.
And I thought that was
the coldest hustle ever.
So I was like, sign
me up for that.
I have lots of questions.
And so the thought
was to really find
a space where I could theorize
about things that vexed me
as a person-- why was
that, at Columbia, I
was one of 5% of students
who attended public schools,
particularly in California?
Why was I often one of
few African-American males
in the spaces that I existed.
And then, in particular, when I
ended up teaching kindergarten
on 110th Street
and Broadway, where
there were 56 kids
in kindergarten,
there was not a
single black boy.
And we are less than 15
blocks away from the center
of [? Harlem. ?] {}
And I watch my kids,
not just my kids of color, I
had a couple of girls of color,
but play house, and the idea
that they couldn't fathom
a little version of me in
their picture was problematic,
and then listening to them
try to make sense of the world
around them.
One of my students,
Jake, at some point
asked me, why is it that
only that girls of color
stay after school?
And then suggested it was
because their mommies didn't
love them.
So watching kids make sense
of the world around them,
and then hearing
things that people
were saying in popular
culture or in their homes,
I struggled with that.
This is after sort of accepting
that I'd always worked
with kids, but
thought that I was not
going to be anybody's teacher.
Just no, don't want anything to
do with it, but everything made
sense for me when I found myself
teaching, first kindergarten,
then third grade.
And at the time, people were
having lots of conversations
about No Child Left Behind.
And so I was in grad
school at the same time,
to sort of supplement
the fact that I
didn't prepare to be
a teacher formally,
and knew that I needed to
do more than just show up
and meet my kids
where they were.
And everybody was talking
about the promise of policy.
And so after a pretty
vexing conversation
in which I made a couple
of classmates cry,
I said that policy
can't be that hard.
I'll move to DC, and
I'll fix it myself.
So I took a pay
cut from teaching.
I became a fellow with the
Congressional Black Caucus
foundation.
I worked for Congressman
Rangel for not quite a year,
and then joined Senator
Kennedy's HELP Committee staff.
The HELP Committee
sees more than 40%
of legislation introduced
in any given Congress,
everything related to health,
education, labor, pensions,
and then a bunch of
other things as well.
And I worked for
him until he passed.
Tom Harkin then
inherited the staff.
And then, over maybe
2 and 1/2 years,
the rise of the
Tea Party sentiment
made it difficult for us to
have bipartisan conversations
in the Senate.
And before I was escorted out
of the building, I quit my job.
I drove all the way across
the country to Nevada
and worked to get the
president reelected.
I was then unemployed,
which I never
thought I would say with
two Ivy League degrees.
But shortly after
the inauguration,
the second inauguration
for the president,
I was then appointed
to this position.
And in the long way of
answering your question,
I said when I was
appointed that,
to say I have been preparing for
this position my entire life is
a gross understatement.
So while, again,
clear that I never
thought that I
would be an educator
or working in Washington, in
hindsight, all of the pieces
lined up.
SUEZETTE ROBOTHAM: So what
is the charge of your office?
And how are you being
tasked with helping
to, not only close the
achievement gap, but moreso
the opportunity gap?
DAVID JOHNS: Yeah,
so my office is
directed by an
eight-page executive
order in which the
president makes
us responsible for
restoring the country
to its right as a
global leader, in part
by increasing the [? polls-- ?]
[LAUGHTER]
Right?
Uh-huh.
Let that sink in.
Right?
That's at the first-- that's
at the header, the lead-in.
Before you even get to
the numbers and stuff.
So "global leader, in
part, by increasing
the number of
African-Americans who
graduate from post-secondary
institutions."
And then it describes the way
that we're supposed to do that,
including everything from
reducing segregation in schools
to increasing access to early
childhood education programs,
addressing disproportionality,
increasing access to STEM
and STEAM.
Everything you have
ever heard somebody
say in relation
to the challenges
that black students or the
educators that support them
face, it is included
in our executive order.
And again, mind you, we were
established in the second term
of this administration.
And because I know that
there are only 254 days
left in this
administration, we chose
to focus our work in three ways.
One is giving a
platform to those
who are impacted by
the decisions that
are made in Washington,
to be able to talk
about that experience.
So I get really annoyed when
invited-- I was just having
this conversation with
somebody around TFA--
when I get invited
into spaces where
the topic is about
opportunities for kids
and there is not a
single child in the room.
Adults reflect upon what it was
like when we were in school,
and then we design solutions
based on the things
that we think we would need.
And it's so problematic.
We then go in to implementing
the solutions that we come up
with, and seldom ask
young people, what
do you think about this?
What matters to you?
And so we have a partnership.
The things that you guys have on
your chair is something we use,
what we call Af-Am Ed summits.
We host them at post-secondary
campuses around the country.
We did one most
recently at UC Davis.
I've done one at Laney
College, U Penn, Morehouse,
a number of schools
across the country.
But the only rule
for the summits
is that the only experts who
get to sit on the dais in front
of the White House, there
are students, elementary age,
high school, college, and
nontraditional and traditional.
And the one question we ask
them, no matter where we are,
is, what do you need so that
you are and feel safe, engaged,
and supported?
Who wants to guess
the answer that always
comes up no matter where we are
or the age of the young person?
Nobody wants to guess?
SUEZETTE ROBOTHAM: It
could be participation.
Anybody want to guess?
AUDIENCE: Ask the
question again, please.
DAVID JOHNS: What's
the-- what do
you need so that you
are and feel safe,
engaged, and supported?
AUDIENCE: Food.
DAVID JOHNS: Food.
What else?
AUDIENCE: Safety.
MALE SPEAKER: Good teachers.
AUDIENCE: Love.
DAVID JOHNS: So she said it.
It seldom comes
up, but it's love.
Often, the things that
typically are our answer,
like money, we need
financial support,
we need access to
curriculum, they
get to that at a certain point.
But at the core what they
say is that we want love.
And not something that is
nebulous, but the love that
comes from a secure
attachment to an adult
that you know will be there for
you when you mess up, when you
make mistakes, when things
don't go the way that they're
supposed to go.
And so that's really
important to us,
is providing platforms
for young people
to really talk about their
truth and to be celebrated
for their experience.
The second thing we do is really
highlight promising practices.
So we try and take
away the excuse
that we don't know
what's working.
And then also try and cut
through a lot of the BS
that people believe about what
black kids are not capable of.
So an example of
this is the idea
that people believe that there
are more black men in prison
than in college, which
is factually inaccurate.
We question whether or not that
statistic has ever been real.
But I taught with people who
believe that, and then they
use that as a way to let
themselves off the hook
when they met a student
that they didn't understand.
He's going to end up
dead or in jail anyway,
so I don't need to do the work.
And the reality is
that right now there
are more than 800,000 black
men on college campuses
than there are in prison.
We're still disproportionately
represented in prison.
But in spite of the
challenges, we still
show up and try-- not only
try, but show out in spaces
that we're not
often supported in.
And so we leverage
things like Twitter.
We host bi-monthly Twitter
chats on Thursdays,
12:00 to 1:00 Eastern
Standard Time, where
we pick a topic
and invite people
to talk about it, in part,
because African-Americans
oversubscribe on social
media, including Twitter.
So we like to slide into the
DMs and disrupt whatever they're
doing, and otherwise find ways
to make critical connections
between, again, things that
might not be accessible
because they're coded in
jargon, whether that's
the tech speak like all these,
the Google acronyms, or policy
speak that the wonks
in DC understand.
And the third
thing is supporting
organizations and
individuals who do that work.
So I am here, in part,
because on Monday, I
gave a keynote at the Oakland
Unified School District
African-American Male
Achievement program.
And that was the first
program that any senior leader
from the administration visited
after President Obama launched
the My Brother's
Keeper initiative.
On Friday, tomorrow,
I guess, I will
be at Chabot College for
the Striving Black Brothers
commencement program.
Again, two organizations
that do the work that
makes all of what's theorized
in my executive order very real.
And because there
is so little time
left in this
administration, every day I
watch the video of
the young girl who
is told that the president is
leaving at a certain point,
and she just wilds out.
That's how I feel.
Because that clock is
ever-present in my mind,
so much of our
work is connecting
with those who have done the
work before this administration
and will be charged with
continuing it after.
SUEZETTE ROBOTHAM: So I want to
go back to something that you
said in terms of social media.
And we are, of course,
Google, and so technology
is a very important part of
moving the work and the ball
forward for our children.
And people can't see your shirt.
But it says #TeachTheBabies.
And that's probably
how I met you.
People keep asking
us how we met.
And I can't really give
them a good story yet.
But I know that a
lot of influence
comes from social media in
terms of building understanding
and awareness.
Social media was also the
birthplace for the Black Lives
Matter movement.
And so how are you
leveraging social media
to build more awareness
and advocacy for the work
that you're doing?
DAVID JOHNS: Yeah.
Social media has been a
really important tool for us,
in part, because we
don't have the resources
that, for example,
the president has.
And so we expended
quite a bit of energy
early on when the
initiative was established,
essentially
establishing profiles
in spaces where we knew we
could engage with, and otherwise
give information to, what
we call our stakeholders.
And I tell my team
that when we think
of who we do our work for, it's
really for people like my mom.
I'm a first-generation
college graduate.
So I always think of your friend
who graduated from college,
but their mom who may have
just finished high school.
Our content has
to be appropriate
for them to be able to
understand it and digest it
in ways that don't
make them confused
or otherwise feel like they
don't know enough to be
able to engage in this space.
And so social media,
in particular Instagram
and Twitter, allow us to
provide content in ways
that extremely
easily digestible.
So an example is, we have a
partnership with the Because
of Them, We Can campaign.
There's another video.
I carry this notebook.
I carry a backpack.
One of my favorite
things to do in schools
is to ask teachers to name
the people on this notepad
or on the backpack.
And surprisingly, most
often, adults can't.
It's like 10 people.
And that's the
people we sometimes
celebrate in February.
And if you think about the
fact that teachers can't do it,
we shouldn't be surprised when
students, then, can't do it,
right?
And so in February,
for example, we
posted an image of, again,
these heroes and sheroes that we
celebrate sometimes
from our future,
but sometimes from
present as well,
and then created
easily-digestible activities
for parents and families to do.
Tell a story.
Create a poem.
Sing a song.
Just find ways to make
meaningful connections.
I have a lot of fun on
Twitter, I think, less now,
maybe because I'm becoming old.
But one of my
favorite things to do
was to be disruptive
during TGIT,
when everybody was
watching "Scandal."
I don't watch "Scandal" anymore.
But I used to be
really into "Scandal."
But I would get
a lot of traction
by saying things like, I know
you broke all kind of laws
to get home, to get your
wine, to be a gladiator,
but did you read to
your kids tonight?
So just finding ways
to interrupt spaces
where sometimes these
conversations don't happen.
And then we think about working
with "Glee," for example,
on a story arc that
included an acknowledgment
of homeless children.
So there's the Elementary
Secondary Education Act
that was just recently
reauthorized in TESAA,
The Every Students Achieve Act.
Title X of the previous bill
was McKinney-Vento, policies
governing just laws
and regulations
around kids who are homeless.
There was a student who, for a
second on "Glee," was homeless,
and they mentioned the
McKinney-Vento Act.
It was a way for us to
talk about something
that is seldom discussed
outside of Washington DC.
I'm sure most y'all have never
heard of McKinney-Vento or even
thought about the fact that
there are laws governing things
related to homeless students.
But again, that's an
opportunity of ways
that we make connections
to try and change things.
One more I'll offer-- a
colleague, Knatokie Ford,
who works on Office of
Science and Technology policy
has a social media and media
project that is essentially
around leveraging popular
culture and media to highlight
opportunities for minorities,
in particular African-Americans
and STEM.
So when you think about-- how
many of you guys watch "CIS"?
No?
I watch "CIS."
And a lot of ratchet TV, too.
But you know, there's
data around the increase
in the number of students
who declare majors related
to forensic sciences and things
that are connected to "CIS."
And so the idea is that
if we can take that, draw
clear connections and
compel other people to make
meaningful connections,
we can otherwise
accelerate opportunities.
If you look at "Black-ish,"
there's been a similar arc
where Yara's character has had
a lot of work in projects around
physics.
That's an intentional
connection to get
us to think about things
that otherwise exist
as amorphous because
sometimes, if black folks are
credentialed, them being a
STEM engineer isn't celebrated
in the same way.
So we just try
and be disruptive.
And social media is
a tool that helps us.
SUEZETTE ROBOTHAM: So
let's talk about synergies,
because I think a lot of what
I keep hearing in your replies
is, like, the synergies
between technology,
and the synergies
between our communities,
and synergies between even
things like social media.
What synergies are we missing
between the education world
and technology world
that would make this
a different place for our kids?
DAVID JOHNS: Good question.
I think three things.
One, we miss opportunities
to make things plain.
I often say that,
everything you need to know,
you learned in kindergarten.
And there's a certain
point when we become adults
where I think the goal is
to make things complicated.
An example of that
is that adults
argue about STEM versus
STEAM, science, technology,
engineering, mathematics
versus science, technology,
engineering, the arts and
agriculture, or mathematics.
And what I say is, I've
never been in a classroom
where students have
ever said stop!
Is this the T or the A?
Where in the acronym do--
they just want to be engaged.
They don't really care
about the jargon or the ways
that we talk about
things or create silos
in spaces where
they don't exist.
And so I think the first thing
is that Google, Googlers,
the all y'all, and whatever
acronyms you belong to, should
think about ways to
make things simple,
and things that are often
rendered invisible made plain.
So for example, a
lot of young kids
are told that they
aren't science-minded,
that they can't be an
engineer, in part because it
was difficult for the
adults around them.
Think about how many times
you've heard somebody say,
math was hard for me, so it's
going to be impossible for you.
Or, I never got that, so you're
not going to get it either.
Or the reality that some
of y'all have experienced,
something about the women
in this room in particular,
that the spaces you occupy,
you're often alone or isolated.
And you just don't want
anybody else to have
to endure that struggle.
And so we end up killing
the dreams of young people
before they ever start to think
about the possibilities that
exist for them in
spaces like this.
The second thing is
related to the jargon.
We don't often develop the
vocabularies of young people
so that they can talk
about the stuff that
happens in these spaces using
the terms that actually exist.
We talk a lot at the initiative
about the importance of using
actual terms that describe
everyday phenomena so that kids
can develop vocabulary
before, again,
they're told that they can't.
So that's everything
from the way
that you observe science
in the natural world
to the connections
that you guys would
make because of the things
that you've studied.
And then I think the third thing
is just sort of showing up.
I've spent a lot of time
now with young people who
say they want to be engineers.
And then, I ask them,
what does that mean?
And then they don't know.
It's almost like STEM is the
new green jobs where everybody's
talking about it,
but very few people
know exactly what it means.
So the question for you
from me is, how do you
make your job visible to young
people who are observing you,
in particular, young people
who are observing you,
and you're not even aware of it?
How do you show up,
whether you're an engineer
and you support
engineering functions,
or whatever it is that you
do, in ways that just make
it accessible for young people?
Does that answer your question?
SUEZETTE ROBOTHAM: That was
perfect. [INAUDIBLE] Of course.
So I hear a lot of myth
busting in your job role,
like, you're constantly
going out, finding the myth,
and then disproving it.
What's the biggest
myth about our kids?
And what do we
need to be thinking
about in terms of turning
that around for them?
DAVID JOHNS: I'm going to
invert that because I try
not to do the deficit thing.
So I don't want to
reaffirm our deficits.
The thing that
keeps me up at night
is the reality that in
too many communities
throughout our country, a
child's access to opportunity
is predicated by a code, a
genetic code or ZIP code.
And I know, in part, because
I meet kids every day
that show up in the way
that I just described,
that Asa Hilliard talks about.
Every child is a genius.
I've never met a child who
asked to be [? birthed. ?]
And the ones who are most
sensitive to the fact
that the environments that
they're forced to endure
aren't conducive
to their well-being
are the ones who deserve our
love and support the most.
And so what am I saying?
One, we often neglect
and ignore the kids
who are most deserving of
our time and attention.
And I'm not just saying
sort of formal educators,
but I mean the way in
which we also show up
as mentors, our sources of
support for young people
that inhabit the
spaces we move through.
Two, we miss the fact that young
kids right now face challenges,
sometimes on the way
to or from school,
that would break
the average adult.
There was a moment
when Mike Brown died,
and we went with the last
Secretary of Education,
Arne Duncan, to Ferguson.
And there were adults who, for
the first time, were thinking,
oh, this is really traumatic.
These kids are experiencing
death for the first time.
And the kid's like, this
the third friend I done
lost this school year.
And there was a-- if I remember
correctly-- Mike Brown was
killed maybe on a Thursday.
The kids were out of school
almost for an entire week.
And they were told during this
break not to talk about it.
And the reality was that
that's all they were doing.
They were group chatting and
snapping and Facebooking.
And they came to
school ready to have
the conversation in
real time that they
had been having virtually.
And the adults
who kid themselves
into thinking that they
weren't going to talk about it,
or just be at home doing
whatever I think people
think the kids do
now, just crazy.
And so I think we missed
that, the literal challenges
that kids face trying to show
up and do the things that we
demand of them.
And then the third thing is
we miss unique opportunities
to address specific challenges.
So the president launched
My Brother's Keeper
as an initiative to highlight
the fact that we often
are numb to the challenges
that boys and men of color,
in particular, face.
The initiative received
a lot of criticism,
in part from black
feminist groups that
suggested that the theory
that we're going to fix things
by focusing on
black men and boys
was false, that if we're
going to do anything,
we need to focus on
black women and girls.
And the problem with
this is that both
are true at the same time.
There's a data point
now that a lot of people
are familiar with.
And it's that for every
one white male who's
suspended or expelled
in K-12, it's
three times that rate
for black men and boys.
The thing that most
people miss now
is that that rate
is six times as
high for black women and girls.
And in major metropolitan spaces
like Atlanta, Georgia, Oakland,
California, black
women and girls
are being pushed out of
schools and their homes,
and being pulled into
things like sex trafficking.
The highest rates
exist in Atlanta.
And that nuance is missed if
you look at the top lines.
The top lines are,
nationally, in the aggregate,
women are doing well.
And they are.
Black women in particular
continue to outstrip black men
proportionately.
However, for high-performing
black women and girls,
as well as for those who
are academically challenged,
they face a lot of
social challenges
that are missed unless we
talk about the nuances.
Similarly, there are
unique challenges
that boys and men of color face.
I think about what it
was like to be followed
by a cop leaving
the airport, then
driving past Fruitvale Station.
There are just things that come
with our lived experience that
sometimes go missed
and unnoticed.
The last thing
I'll say about this
is that sometimes we don't even
think about the trauma that's
inflicted upon children.
We debate sometimes
in social media
whether or not
black lives matter.
And there are students
who hear that question,
and then go into spaces where
people affirm for them whether
or not it does or doesn't.
Their humanity,
whether or not it
matters, whether or not
it's of consequence.
And when we don't think about
the social and emotional health
and well-being of
our kids, sometimes
it becomes too much about
their cognitive growth
and how well they're doing on
computer science assessments,
or if they're ready
for the AP, when
we miss the social and
emotional piece, the importance
of mental health, we do
everyone a huge disservice.
SUEZETTE ROBOTHAM: So then
what are five concrete things,
and I'll give you a range.
Give me three to five concrete
things that each of us
can do to be asset-based
and asset-focused in terms
of supporting, not only
our schools, because we
know the unit of
change is actually
in the school building,
in school communities.
DAVID JOHNS: Interesting.
I'm going to back into this by
highlighting policy areas that
have been most important
in terms of our work,
and then try and make
some direct connections
to the group.
So the areas where we
focused our attention--
and when I say
our, I'm referring
not only to the
initiative that I run,
but our work in support of
our President's Advisory
Commission, of some
27 folks, including
Freeman Hrabowski, who
is president of UMBC,
runs the Meyerhoff
Scholars Program,
gets a whole of minority
folks into MD-PhD programs.
They focus their
efforts in three areas.
One is increasing access to
high-quality early learning
programs.
So the thing that's
important here
is that learning
starts at birth.
But the preparation for learning
starts well before birth.
And we spend a
whole lot of time,
in particular in the
African-American community,
talking about school
beginning in kindergarten,
or playing catch-up thereafter.
And the data shows that
African-American students are
most likely to be
enrolled somewhere,
whether that's childcare,
Head Start, Early Head Start,
or some other pre-K program.
But the quality is
always questionable.
The very opposite is true
for our Latino brothers
and sisters.
And I'm acknowledging
that some of us
exist in the intersections,
and are Afro-Latino,
and other derivations thereof.
But for the Hispanic
community more
generally, the tendency
is for the babies
to be in what we call, FF
and N-- family, friend,
and neighbor care.
But when they are
enrolled in the program,
it's of high quality.
So we have to do
the work of both,
increasing the number of
black babies and families
that are in high-quality
early learning programs,
but then improving the quality
of those at the same time.
So if you all know somebody that
has a child who is under five,
ask them, are they enrolled
in a high-quality early care
and education program?
And if not, there are resources.
There are childcare
resource referral agencies.
There's Thrive by Five.
There are all kind of things,
in particular in California,
that you can refer them to
to help connect that dot.
The second area that we
focused on increasing access
to meaningful
pre-K-12 curriculum,
including by focusing
on STEM and STEAM.
So what does this mean for us?
One, access to computer science
as a basic prerequisite.
We know that there are seven
states in this country where
you can not take a computer
science course at all.
And then access is also
disproportionate in spaces
where one can take a
computer science course.
And so, in addition to talking
about access to curriculum,
we're working at a
federal level to increase
the support for
public institutions,
or institutions that
leverage public resources,
to provide meaningful
experiential opportunities
for kids to learn STEM skills.
So sometimes that
looks like, you guys
might know Upward Bound
programs, or things
that traditionally cost
a whole lot of money
and are reserved for
really privileged people.
So that's the second area.
The third area is increasing
college graduation
or completion.
And when we say college,
we mean, specifically
two- and four-year institutions,
credential, certificate,
or degrees of value.
And we focus
specifically-- bless you--
on reducing the
need for and time
spent in developmental
or remedial ed.
So some, more than 60%
of African-Americans
who begin a
post-secondary program,
don't finish because
they get stuck
in developmental education or
non-credit-bearing coursework.
So we work with
institutions or systems
like the University of Texas
to try and change that.
So those are three
policy, programmatic areas
that I think are worthy of
additional consideration.
But there are two
things that I think
everybody can do, no matter
how you show up in this.
One is to support the
learning and development
of a young person.
So I'll often say
the first thing
to think about is teaching.
We often don't think about that.
But teaching-- people
say silly things
like, teaching isn't
rocket science.
They're right.
It's a lot harder.
I have a NASA scientist
who confirms with that.
And so if you can't
teach, you can mentor.
And you can do that in groups.
You can do it with other
people so that you find ways
to hold yourself accountable.
But showing up in the
lives of young people
is critically important.
And then the second
thing related
to that is just to listen
to young people, really
give them opportunities
to talk about what's
going on in their world
and then to enroll you
in the process of
supporting them.
How often have you brought
a young person just
to this campus to imagine
what life could be like
if they continue to do
the things that they're
asked to do?
We sometimes go back
to-- I went to Columbia.
So we don't really
tailgate there.
But I know some of y'all go to
schools where they tailgate.
SUEZETTE ROBOTHAM: Go Gators.
DAVID JOHNS: You turn
up for the party.
But do you take
young people with you
to, again, say,
imagine what life
could be like for
you if you, again,
do the things that sometimes
can be difficult to do
because life gets in the way.
I think that's five.
SUEZETTE ROBOTHAM: I
mean, you hit the mark.
I'm not disappointed.
So let's go back to David the
man and David the journey.
So everybody who
knows me knows I
will toot your horn for you if
you won't toot your own horn.
You were recently named a young
alum of valor and distinction
for Columbia University.
We know that the administration
is coming to an end
pretty soon.
What are you thinking
about in terms
of just your continued
trajectory within this space?
And where might David be in
the next five to 10 years?
DAVID JOHNS: I don't know.
But I know that for three
months after January 20, 2017,
David will be somewhere on
a beach where there's no--
[LAUGHTER]
--no cell phone reception,
no Twitter, no Instagram,
no nothing.
SUEZETTE ROBOTHAM: You
realize that doesn't
work for me, though.
DAVID JOHNS: I'm sorry, ma'am.
[LAUGHTER]
That is-- people
laughing, I'm so serious.
For two reasons,
one again, this job
didn't exist when
I was an undergrad.
And I had to move
through the process
of-- I was a kid
who had a plan A,
and then the back-up
plan just to make sure
that plan A happened, and
then another one just in case
that one didn't go through.
I long let go of that and
really abide by the importance
of walking by faith.
So much of my, what
I'm now celebrated for,
which is still weird-- even
when people read my bio,
I'm like, oh, that's
kind of crazy.
So much of what I've
done is simply show up
and find ways to leverage
my privilege and purpose
to do better for others.
And so I don't
really know what I
will do in terms of employment.
I will likely be unemployed.
I'm OK with that.
Got a good accountant.
But it's really important
for me to take a break.
I took this job knowing that I
could run as fast as possible
for a defined number of days.
There are 253 left.
And then, at that point,
take a break, in part,
because this work
is all-consuming.
To do the work of
advocating on behalf
of children who are often
neglected and ignored
is crazy-making.
I often have to travel
and engage with and visit
with young people to be reminded
that the work is important.
Because when you
sit with adults who
don't understand that
somebody invested in them
and that other kids
need the same support,
it can sometimes
drain you in ways
that, if you're
not thoughtful of,
can make it difficult,
if possible at all,
to do the work.
So I'm not trying to
be funny or flippant,
but I'm taking a
break, a real break.
SUEZETTE ROBOTHAM:
I need you to have--
DAVID JOHNS: You'll
be all right with it.
SUEZETTE ROBOTHAM:
--cell phone reception.
DAVID JOHNS: Nope.
[?
SUEZETTE ROBOTHAM: Doesn't
?] [? work for me. ?]
So awesome.
And how do we find
you on social media?
DAVID JOHNS: I am
@MrDavidJohns on everything,
and then use the
hashtag #TeachTheBabies.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
Hello, everyone.
I'm Greg Hammons, and I'm with
the Accounting and Compliance
team.
Thanks so much
for coming, David.
I just have a question
about, like you said,
you're going to go and take a
break, the well-deserved trip.
And so I just wonder, as far
as the initiative, what's
happening?
Is it going to continue?
Who's taking your place?
Or what can we expect?
DAVID JOHNS: Good question.
So the precedent is
that the initiatives
continue regardless of the
political party in power.
So the HBCU initiative,
the eldest of them
was established under
Carter, and it's continued
via executive order since then.
And the expectation is that
this one will continue as well.
I spent, probably, 90%
of my time on the road,
in part, supporting stakeholders
that, should anybody
ever attempt to even try and
change something significant,
there'll be lots of pushback,
not only from the Black Caucus,
but from the community as well.
And there is a deputy
director, a young woman,
she's a PhD Student at the
University of Virginia, who's
on staff now who is being
groomed to take over
when I get to take a break.
AUDIENCE: You know,
so there are a lot
of African-American
students that
are in these predominantly,
majority school districts.
What sort of work is being
done for that population?
Because I do feel
like that population
tends to be forgotten,
where we're definitely
focusing in areas that are
obviously very critical.
But what are we doing to support
those students, particularly
in a place like California,
where there's a lot of suicides
that are happening
in districts that
are very close to this
location here in Sunnyvale?
Just curious to
see if you've been
focused on this issue
at all in your work.
DAVID JOHNS: Yes.
So really important,
three things.
One, I talk a lot about
the HBCU initiative,
in part, because our executive
order includes language
that essentially mandates that
we supplement, not supplant,
their efforts.
And so this is a
really important nuance
because often when people
think about black students
in post-secondary spaces, they
think about historically black
college and universities.
And they provide an
essential service
to our country and community.
But 90% of black kids in
college are at white schools.
And so we exist,
in part, because we
need to focus on
all of the places
where black students are
learning, and/or people are
entrusted with their
learning and development,
and highlighting
that as one of them.
The second thing, I
think-- I guess is two.
One is focusing on
curriculum expansion.
So another thing that comes
up at a lot of our summits
is the need for everybody,
not just students of color,
but for everybody to be more
aware of the contributions
that African descendants
have made to American history
or to global history.
And so we're working now
with the College Board
to create an AP exam in
African-American history
because we know, that
which is tested is taught.
And that will be
a way for us to be
more thoughtful and
expansive in how
it is that we educate
everybody and celebrate
the fact that, when things
are diverse, we all win.
This is also directly
related to the fact
that there are a
couple of states
in the South in particular
that are now forcing educators
to teach things like Confederate
history, which would make
a lot of the challenges that
we're working through now,
related to the Black Lives
Matter stuff, more complicated.
Specific to the question
of mental health,
we have a number
of partnerships,
including with Kappa Alpha
Psi Fraternity, Incorporated,
the greatest fraternity
known to man.
SUEZETTE ROBOTHAM: Right.
DAVID JOHNS: Listen, Linda.
--to focus on mental health.
So what we know is that
the number of suicide
rates for black boys, in
particular, school-aged,
has doubled in
the last 20 years.
And so while we spend a lot
of time focused on-- right--
we spend a lot of time focused
on state-sanctioned violence,
we're missing the
fact that we're
not, again, addressing
the mental health
needs of our children.
And so we partnered
with, not only
with Kappa Alpha Psi, but
Susan Taylor's CARES mentoring,
to talk about the role
of toxic stress, trauma,
and prolonged
exposure to poverty,
and really drawing
the connection
between those physiological
things that sometimes
are discussed in health
spaces, and their implications
in education more formally.
So a lot of it for us right
now is, not only gap filling,
but then highlighting
where we need
to be focusing more attention.
And that is obviously
one of them.
AUDIENCE: So my question
is-- you actually just
touched on it.
I was wondering about
the ramifications
you've seen thus far.
I mean, it's only been one term.
But as you were talking
about mental health,
just wondering about the
work that your office might
be doing with the US Public
Health Service, just in
regards to things like
access and education.
Because we've seen
that, in this country,
your health outcomes
are most directly
influenced by your
income, but we
see that that doesn't apply
to minority communities.
So you have instances of where
white high school dropout
females have better
birth outcomes
than college-educated
black women,
when, in fact, it
should be the opposite.
What kind of work,
or is there any work
being done between your
office and that initiative
and the US Public Health
Services in regards
to tackling economic--
MALE SPEAKER: That's fine.
AUDIENCE: --racial and
ethnic health disparities
that are being
directly influenced
by economics, poverty,
continued exposure
to-- like you're
saying-- stress,
having to, as we
always say, work
twice as hard to get half
as much, all of those
things that have real
physical consequences.
Are you seeing any
major strides being
made in terms of looking
at the physical health
of our communities as a
direct outcome of the work
that you all are doing?
DAVID JOHNS: Yes.
And I try and take
my ego out of it.
I don't know how much of
it is a direct relation,
or is correlated to things
that we've done specifically.
But I think a lot of it just
has to do with federal movement
around health care.
So remember first term of
this administration, everybody
expended energy to get the
Affordable Care Act passed,
in part, because we use a lot
of that money that was saved
from taking back the
loan service provision
that banks did so that the
federal government can do it
from direct lending.
I know some of y'all were
impacted by this thing and got
a little bit more money
in your bank accounts.
But this was, in part,
because we were also
able to highlight the role that
schools and institutions could
play in addressing the health
challenges of communities,
in particular, that don't access
traditional forms of care.
So there are three things
that come up for us.
One is highlighting the
role that navigators play
and connecting communities that
traditionally are leery of,
or untrusting of,
health care providers
so that they can access care, in
particular, preventative care.
Two, we spent a lot
of time highlighting
the benefits of the
Affordable Care Act
and the need for families, in
particular, our communities,
to take advantage of
them, one, the benefits
that were afforded to
women, in particular,
around prenatal care and health.
And then, two, the benefits
that were afforded to children
who might not have previously
been able to get coverage
because they have
a condition that
would have made them excluded
under the previous health
care laws.
The third thing,
and this goes back
to the question you just
asked, the two things
that we spend a
lot of time talking
about with our stakeholders,
with our communities,
are one, the need for us to move
beyond celebrating resilience.
So this is a personal
thing for me.
And the First Lady
does a wonderful job
of highlighting the work
required for young people,
in particular in
communities like mine
in Inglewood, California,
to show up and be
successful in spite of.
But the question I'm now
asking, and this just came up
when we were AAER, the American
Association of Education
Research is, at what cost?
So to go back to
"Scandal" and the line
that you just mentioned,
second season of "Scandal"
opened with Liv being at an
airport hangar with Papa Pope.
And he said to her, what's
the one thing I always
taught you growing up?
And she couldn't even look
him in the eye and said,
I have to work twice as hard
just to get half as far.
And it was like the thing
heard around the world.
What person of
color hasn't heard
that in some way, shape, or
form, if not multiple times
over their lifetime.
And the question for me
is, but at what cost,
mentally, physically,
emotionally, psychologically?
What is the toll of you
always showing up in spite of,
and what does it
do to young people?
And so we're now working with
a couple of institutions,
including the Urban Institute,
to develop a research agenda
so that we actually have data
to move past the anecdotal.
But if nothing else, I highlight
the fact that it's happening
and that we need
to be mindful of it
with regard to
supporting our kids.
This came up at the
AAMA celebration
of [INAUDIBLE] gospel.
A lot of what they
did was say to kids,
you all just need to keep going
to school and doing whatever.
Y'alls need to keep going
and reading these books.
And that's true.
But adults also have
a responsibility
to change the institution
so that they're welcoming,
that they're
supportive, but also
to address things that often
go unacknowledged, which
is, again, the
implications of having
to do the kind of work
that happens when we
don't make these connections.
AUDIENCE: Teachers of color and
school leaders of color, what--
how your work kind of touches
that, or what you guys
are looking to, so how to
support those teachers.
DAVID JOHNS: So
that comes up often.
The thing that we
talk most about
is the need to address
diversity within the workforce.
Less than 2% of the
teaching workforce
looks like me, and especially
at the earliest levels.
The fact that I was a black
man teaching in kindergarten
was just crazy, in part, because
there's a lot of work that
needs to be done socially.
People still think that
the work is feminized
and that men who
are interested in it
are either pedophiles or
just socially awkward, which
I try and refute every day.
[LAUGHTER]
So that's one.
But then the second
thing is really
to highlight the
importance of it.
So Freeman Hrabowski
talks about the fact
that educators do God's work.
But we live in a
society that does not
value that in the same way.
And then when
people try and find
creative approaches
to doing that,
think about the districts that
have been paying educators
more than six figures and
all these other things,
people get criticized for it.
And so what we try to do
is address that by, one,
highlighting the role that
African-American educators who
are already in the field play--
[NOTIFICATION SOUND]
Hey.
--already in the field
play, that the importance
of doing this work, two,
talking to young kids.
I say to them,
educators do God's work.
You need to think
about teaching.
I did this talk at
Howard, where I was like,
my goal is to get y'all
to think about-- right.
Also did it at
Morehouse as well.
AUDIENCE: Spellman.
DAVID JOHNS: OK.
I didn't do it at Spellman--
AUDIENCE: You did.
DAVID JOHNS: --but it was
right across the campus.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
But again, going to
these spaces and talking
about the importance
of doing this work,
and, again, acknowledging that
teaching isn't for everybody.
But we should all consider the
ways in which we can show up.
And then, practically
thinking about the ways
that the federal government
can be helpful or supportive.
So there was just a week
ago, actually maybe it
was this-- no.
Last Monday, there
was a convening
around diversity
in the workforce
where we leveraged data
around recruitment, retention,
and advancement of
a diverse workforce.
And I mean diverse in
every sense of the word,
not just black.
I'm talking about able-bodied,
not able-bodied, LGBTQ,
every form of
diversity, in part,
because the thing that
I always think about
is we have this
screening and discussion
series, a partnership
with Motion Picture
Association of
America and ASPIRE,
again, show up in
places where people are.
We show films that are only
positive in relation to how
we can support our
kids, things like
"The Inevitable Defeat
of Mister and Pete,"
a wonderful film
that you all should
see about the resilience
of black children
and what it means for us
to think that they're not
capable of succeeding in school
when they succeed in life,
sometimes by themselves.
The film that we're
showing in two weeks
is "3 and 1/2 Minutes."
It's the film about
Jordan Davis, who
was murdered in a gas station.
And Lucia McBath, his mom,
and I had this discussion
on an Essence panel where
she sat next to my mom
and said that she knew when
the police called and told
her what transpired that it
had happened in that way,
that somebody said to her
son, you can't do something.
And he said, to hell with that.
I'm going to do it anyway.
Because she raised him
to advocate for himself.
But the thing that I will go
to my grave fearing and knowing
is that if Michael Dunn, the
man who shot Jordan Davis,
had a black male teacher
at some point in his life,
who he saw conspire for
his success, who he felt
loved him in ways
that were authentic,
that altercation would
have happened differently.
And so sometimes the
conversation around diversity
becomes very one-dimensional.
And it's often like, black
kids need to see black people.
That's important, too.
We all need to see versions
of ourselves reflected
in the world around us.
But the more important
thing is to see
people who don't look like us,
who conspire for our success.
That's why the work
is really important.
So we try and highlight
that now, and then
work with organizations
that are doing that work.
AUDIENCE: My question is, what
can we do, like right now?
DAVID JOHNS: I have some
projects you all can invest in.
No.
Let me stop.
I'm serious.
Let's talk about that offline.
What can you do now?
One, find two young people to
carry with you along the way.
And one should be-- so that the
natural, like the young person
that you probably now just
conjured up in your mind
because they do backflips down
the library stacks on Saturday.
But the other one should
be one that challenges you,
one that you want to shake,
in part, because it'll
be that one which will keep
you honest in doing the work
required to show up
for a young person.
And when you make
the commitment,
make it knowing that you have
to be honest, in particular
around the failures that have
allowed you to be successful.
There's something
else that happens,
I think for adults, where
we become successful,
and whatever the
hell that means,
and then we don't talk about
the challenging moments.
And so when it happens
for young people,
they think that they're
the only one who
ever has to deal with it.
This is, in part, why
in June of this year
we're hosting, for
the first time ever,
a White House Summit on
black LGBTQ students.
Y'all aren't alone.
Y'all been showing up and
showing up for decades.
And we need to be
mindful of what's
required to create
environments in which you can,
not only exist, but thrive,
the very opposite of addressing
the challenges that go when we
don't talk about toxic stress
or health implications.
So find two young people
to carry with you.
The second, find ways to make
very transparent and real
the world that you exist
in for those around you.
So this space is hallowed
ground for most folks.
People think Google, they think
y'all got like helicopters
flying around and
robots delivering stuff.
People don't know
what's going on here.
And so the question is,
how do you share the magic,
the thing that keeps you
here for all of the hour that
y'all are here, all
this food y'all consume?
How do you share
that with people
in ways that will help them
make meaningful connections?
Practical example.
We were in Atlanta
at a STEM high school
and asked an auditorium
of kids, how many of you
know a STEM professional?
Two kids raised their hands.
Two.
At a STEM high school.
We then said, how many of you
know somebody that does hair?
20 of them raised their hand.
How many of you
know somebody that
owns a business where
they clean something,
industrial or otherwise?
The lesson for me
there was that we
had to make real the things that
are often rendered invisible
when we talk about
credentials and jargon
in ways that obfuscate the
fact that people show up.
They make innovation.
They do things.
So how do you take the
world that you exist in
and sometimes take
for granted-- how
do you share your privilege is
the simple way of putting it.
Because all of us
have, for the fact
that we're sitting here right
now having this conversation,
is an indication of that.
So how do you share
that with someone.
And in particular,
when you think
about the workforce implications
of this, the work that-- DBOP?
What's y'alls name?
SUEZETTE ROBOTHAM: GBOP.
DAVID JOHNS: GBOP.
I'll be getting it by
the end of the day.
When you think about
the work that GBOP does,
how do you unlock the
hidden curriculum?
Even the fact-- we were
just laughing about this.
Suezette said, don't walk
up in here in a suit.
That's meaningful in
a space like this,
because y'all might have
thought that I was crazy.
It would have been a fly suit.
But I'm saying, it doesn't
work in this space.
So how did you unlock
the hidden curriculum
in ways that make the
connection meaningful?
And then, I think
the third thing
is to be intentional about
finding ways for each of you
to have uncomfortable
conversation.
So I appreciate that
this room is diverse.
I don't appreciate, sometimes,
that we have-- it's just
black folks that want to show
up and talk about black kid
issues.
One thing that I struggled
with taking this job,
do I want to be the
black man appointed
by the black president working
on things just for black kids?
And the implications
are larger, in part,
because we live in a
really diverse society.
And so I'm asking each of you
to not leave all of this here.
We could have had an entirely
separate but related talk
just about intersections of
race and racism and power
and privilege.
A lot of-- to your question
about pathways, why I'm here
is because I was at a very
privileged institution that
was struggling with a lack of
civility as a result of people
being really ignorant
and privileged.
My senior year at Columbia, my
classmates showed their asses.
There was an anti-affirmative
action bake sale
that started at UC
Berkeley and then migrated
its way to the East Coast.
There was a marching band that
aimed to be offensive and put
up flyers.
One had Michael Jackson as a
black boy then as a white woman
and it said, who
needs ethnic studies,
when there had been a hunger
strike that was on campus
for the 30 days prior to that.
The "Federalist" paper published
a cartoon called "Blacky Fun
Whitey" starring
Kunta [? Kornelios ?]
and Stepin that said
black people were invented
in the 1700s as a
cheap form of labor,
parodied all of
our contributions
through sports and
entertainment, and that said,
don't worry, black people do
lots of other wacky things.
But you don't have to worry
about that until next Black
History Month.
This was in 2004 at
Columbia University
in the middle of New York,
where, again, the consequences
of us refusing to do the
uncomfortable work of talking
about race and racism and
privilege and ignorance
continues to show up.
And it often shows up in
really devastating ways
in the lives of young people
who don't have the privilege
to take themselves out
of certain spaces are
to be protected because they've
lived in a certain community
or can't associate with
a certain community.
So I'm asking you
to do that work,
to really talk about the things
that can often go unstated
when you just focus
in on the technology,
and to really think about
how it is that you leverage
the privilege that exists,
not only in each of you
individually, but
in this institution,
to make some of these
meaningful connections
for the children who
you should be preparing
to take your seats in a
not-so-distant future.
SUEZETTE ROBOTHAM: Amen.
[APPLAUSE]